one of my clients was facing issues with
traditional supply chain management so i
stepped in and designed a blockchain
alternative for him all this was
possible thanks to the training i
received from simplylung's blockchain
program
keeping your customers happy should be
the goal of every business
hi i am ashwin fotapathy i am 28 and i
am the co-founder and director of
technology at central and by chains
prime limited a 9-5 job never made sense
to me i always wanted to be my own boss
so last year i started my company along
with my brother
our startup deals with providing clients
with blockchain framework and
application solutions
in india many companies are still
hesitant to try blockchain so my main
focus is to make our clients aware of
the benefits of shifting to blockchain
and ultimately help them run their
business smoothly
but to do that you must yourself be
aware of the technology and be confident
otherwise nobody will trust you with
their mind in april this year i chose
simply learn's postgraduate
certification was in blockchain in an
association with iit kanpur to build
that confidence i am now serving my
clients better
in fact recently we designed a
blockchain alternative for our client
who was facing issues with supply chain
management we implemented the framework
and it is working really well for them
they were able to scale up their import
and export procedures
and we are providing such solutions to
our clients regularly
it wouldn't have been possible without a
course in blockchain
although i hold an mtech degree in
computer applications blockchain was new
to me
so i was looking for a professional
course but at the same time i did not
want to spend a lot of money because my
startup is still in early stage
my experience with simply learn has been
amazing i would say that the
instructions were really helpful one of
my faculty members helped me solve the
hyperledger rollout problem
he told me about his own experience i
was able to apply the enterprise version
of blockchain after that i was able to
anticipate and solve my business
problems
this was a personal touch i just want to
thank him once again